supermodel viotti Prinsloo opens up
about her hubby Adam Levine and reveals
the secret to her killer bikini body the
26 year old is not only a stunning
Victoria's Secret supermodel she's also
a loving wife to maroon 5 frontman adam
levine after tying the knot in july 2014
the couple marked their romance in a
pretty permanent way we heard that you
guys have matching tattoos is that true
it's so funny like I've had it for a
long time where is it it's on my side
yeah but it's not in you it's not a new
thing it was it what did you guys get
them together when you first got married
your home yeah we got we first got it
together when we got married but that's
just the tip of the iceberg for Adam the
singer is covered in tats he recently
revealed a photo of a giant design
spanning his entire back he just loved
the image it's kind of an old school
sailor jerry kind of vibe you know and
him and his tattoo artist just worked on
it for a really long time and he I
approve et was with prinsloo on Tuesday
in LA talking all about the victoria
secret swimsuit special airing wednesday
on CBS with a body like that we had to
know how she keeps her figure looking so
flawless the secret is like you know you
have to keep it up all year your kind
just be like oh it's summer I'm gonna do
a few things here and there I work out
you know almost I mean not every like
twice a week I would say and in
California it's so easy
you